ja also ich bin natürlich überzeugt
davon dass man Russland jetzt irgendwo
natürlich auch zeigen muss das was sie
da jetzt völkerrechtlich wieder richtig
gemacht haben dass das natürlich Einhalt
geboten sein muss das ist klar aber die
Sanktionen dass die natürlich dann dem
sanktionierer auch selber schaden das
ist auch klar weil sonst wenn man
dadurch einen Beziehung hat zu einem
Land und dann ist an der sanktioniere
und der sanktionierte natürlich
gleichermaßen betroffen und ich sage
auch nicht dass die Sanktionen jetzt
völlig sozusagen Hilfe sagen wir mal
wirkungslos sind also wenn ich überlegt
ihr im Großstadt wäre normalerweise
sagen wir morgen 4% gewachsen nächstes
Jahr jetzt haben sie eine Schrumpfung
von -3 %. das äh und Sanktionen die
müsste man natürlich so fein justieren
dass sie langfristig halten können weil
nur langfristig springen sie etwas und
natürlich auf die Militärtechnologie auf
die Möglichkeiten Russland sozusagen
diese auch zu begrenzen und da sehe ich
halt keine fein Markierung sondern
einfach generell dann Ansatz wo man
viele Sanktionen angefangen hat und dann
hat man selber gemerkt naja zum Beispiel
junge Mittel das bringt nichts dann hat
man das wieder gelockert die
Niederländer die haben das ein oder
andere gelockert dann haben die
Amerikaner selber einiges gelockert weil
man gemerkt hat also dass das von
vornherein handwerklich als falsch
gemacht wird insofern die Sanktionen
wenn sie dann einem selber deutlich mehr
Schaden und da muss man die Rolle von
Deutschland besonders verstehen wir sind
ein Exportland aber diese Exporte die es
hängen sozusagen von Ressourcen von
günstigen Importen aber also wie
importieren 1,2 Billionen und
exportieren 1,4 so das heißt also wir
haben hier so unseren bias und gerade
als
energieintensives in der Land sind wir
sozusagen daran abhängig an den
Ressourcen und es ist ja nicht nur Gas
und Öl was wir als Russland bekommen
sondern die ganzen Edelmetalle die
ganzen assistenung Gas oder wenn wir
jetzt sozusagen später über nuklear
sozusagen Kernkraft der dann auch das
Studium viele unterschätzen das Russland
natürlich seit der Oktoberrevolution
eigentlich mit Sanktionen gelebt hat ja
das heißt also wenn man das in
akademischen geraden jetzt vergleicht
dann haben die Russen vielleicht ein PhD
in sanktions- und Umgang Sanktionen da
sind wir noch Grundschüler und deswegen
wirkt das bei uns natürlich umso
schlimmer und all diese Möglichkeiten
und diese Wirkungen hätte man mit
berücksichtigen müssen und dann
feinjustierte wirklich effektive
Maßnahmen was ist die Wirkung wie
schwarz sehen Sie für die deutsche
Wirtschaft wie stark treffen die uns
also ich denke wenn wir werden jetzt die
die Gaspreise zum Beispiel um mehr als
das Doppelte steigen dann ist es mit
unserer Ingenieurs Kunst vorbei ja weil
wir ohnehin schon teuer sind wir haben
sehr großen
sozialapparat wir haben sehr großen
gesundheitsapparat das ist auch gut und
schön das ist ja auch ein Zeichen
unseres Wohlstands aber um das alles zu
finanzieren sind wir auf günstige
Ressourcen günstige Energien angewiesen
und die kommen nun mal aus Russland die
kann man jetzt nicht so substituieren
klar man kann LNG kaufen dann ist das
das sieben zehnfache sozusagen dessen
was aus Russland und man kann alles
ersetzen technisch alles möglich sie
wollen aber sie wurden mit Putin reden
wollen jetzt ich war von Anfang an der
Meinung dass man natürlich diesen
Konflikt irgendwann
sozusagen diplomatisch lösen muss also
dass man sozusagen halt auch Putin
zeigen muss wo er seine wo seine Grenzen
sind und niemand weder Putin noch sehr
lensky werden hier mit
Maximalforderungen hier rauskommen beide
Seiten müssen sicherlich auch zu einem
Kompromiss finden und der Kompromiss war
ja in Istanbul ja auch sehr nah und dann
hat es ja dann doch nicht geklappt und
das Ende vom Lied ist ja dass dann
sozusagen die Forderungen der Russen bzw
das was sie an Territorien einnehmen ja
exponentiell steigt und dann fragt man
sich naja am Anfang hätten das auch ein
bisschen günstiger haben können also
insofern ist das auch diese diese
wartepolitik also weight MC kommt eher
schadet er den Ukrainern und
spüre schon bei ihnen dass sie da nicht
so ganz zustimmen nein
sagen wir es mal so das was sie ja
vorschlagen ist im Endeffekt dass wir
kleinen beigeben und das das im
Endeffekt ja die Rechnung von Russland
aufgeht dass man nur lang genug
irgendwie Krieg führen muss und nur
aggressiv genug sein muss um das Ganze
um im Endeffekt dann doch etwas zu
gewinnen was mir fehlt in in ihrer
Ausführung ist eigentlich die Frage
nicht wie wie bekommen wir wieder Gas
aus Russland und unter welchen Umständen
sondern wie schaffen wir endlich eine
Energiepolitik in Deutschland die uns
insgesamt autark macht also die
grundsätzlich mal darüber nachdenkt dass
Energieversorgung auch eine
Sicherheitspolitik ist und dass diese
dass wir darüber überhaupt nicht reden
wir haben das finden Sie selbst auf der
Seite des Bundesumweltamtes wir haben in
Deutschland Gasvorräte für für unseren
Verbrauch in den nächsten 100 Jahren wir
müssten sie nur selber fördern das heißt
wir machen einen frackingverbot kaufen
aber freckengas woanders das ist nicht
wirklich sozusagen schlüssig ja wir
schaffen die Atomkraft ab kaufen aber
atomstrophe aus dem Ausland ja drei
dürfen wir weiter in sich genau aber
auch das ist ja nicht schlüssig das
heißt mir fehlt bei dieser ganzen
Überlegung fehlt einfach das Konzept und
das auf das warte ich nach wie vor von
unserer Regierung wie eigentlich unser
Land insgesamt nachhaltig in die Zukunft
gedacht autark wird von all diesen
Überlegungen wem wir jetzt wie
Entgegenkommen müssen damit wir
freundlicherweise Energie aus dem
Ausland mit gute reden wäre für sie
keine Option man kann das auch nicht ich
glaube dass diese die die Sanktionen
Grund selbstverständlich Schaden die
Sanktionen auch Deutschland das sieht ja
jeder also wie das abzustreiten ist ja
Banane aber die Frage ist was steht
insgesamt auf dem Spiel also meine
Befürchtung ist eigentlich wenn man
jetzt hier einlenkt dass das Putin jetzt
nicht so versteht wie wir das gerne
verstanden wissen wollen sondern dass es
eine Ermutigung ist demnächst weil
anders
und nein es gibt ja auch noch andere
Gründe es gibt ja noch andere Länder ich
meine nicht umsonst nicht umsonst
irgendwie drängen drängelce drängeln
jetzt Länder in die NATO äh weil sie
sehen es ist eine Gefahr und diese es
ist schon vor 15 Jahren falsch gemacht
worden
dass man da nicht schon reagiert hat und
gesagt hat Moment das geht nicht wer
annektieren keine Länder mehr mitten in
Europa und jetzt wäre sozusagen wieder
eine Ermutigung und das ist das was ich
befürchte zwei Themen drin jetzt auf der
einen Seite über Sanktionen da kann man
fällt mir einiges sein und auf der
anderen Seite diskutieren wir darüber
wie soll eigentlich dieser Krieg
weitergehen oder zu Ende gehen da sind
ja aber natürlich Sanktionen ein großer
Teil davon ne aber ich würde das ich
würde das wirklich zwei Teilen das eine
zum Thema Krieg sollen wir mit Putin
reden natürlich sollen wir mit Putin
reden sonst also momentan tun wir das
nicht aber es ist dringend geboten ich
glaube wir rücken wirklich jeden Tag in
dem dieser Auseinandersetzung eskaliert
und das tut sie rücken wir am dritten
Weltkrieg näher und den möchte ich nicht
erleben die möchte keiner von uns
erleben also müssen wir alles aber auch
wirklich alles dafür tun dass du
verhindern
Bombe zünde
der putin ist unberechenbar und das ist
ja sein das ist ja auch seine Karte die
er spielt dass man nichts genau weiß das
ist das ist eine Strategie insofern
traust ihm zu vielleicht macht das
vielleicht macht das nicht das ist jetzt
nicht das
aber auf jeden Fall den Draht zu diesem
Machthaber zu diesem Diktator weiter zu
suchen und immer wieder auch zu
versuchen dort die Diplomatie ins Spiel
zu bringen das ist glaube ich ganz ganz
wichtig das andere Thema Sanktionen ich
glaube mit Sanktionen das ist die
einzige mögliche Antwort unterhalb des
militärischen Eingreifens die einzig
mögliche Antwort der EU oder des Westens
auf diesen Überfall waren Sanktionen die
lösen einen Wirtschaftskrieg aus und in
einem Wirtschaftskrieg gibt es nur
Verlierer aber beide Seiten verlieren
bringen die dann was diese Aktion ihrer
Meinung nach irgendwas die bringen was
und das lässt sich an einem ganz
einfachen Beispiel auch belegen sie
haben Recht die Sanktionen tun uns sehr
sehr weh all das was hier passiert 19
Grad im Winter das tut wirklich weh
aber nach all dem was wir jetzt
abschätzen können werden wir im nächsten
Jahr in eine Rezession schlittern wir
werden einen minus beim beim
wirtschaftlichen Entwicklung haben das
Licht irgendwo zwischen 0,8 und -2% und
Windows nach allem was man von Russland
weiß wird es deutlich stärker ausfallen
wie die geringsten Schätzungen liegen
bei -6% und da frage ich sie dann bringt
es bei uns doch eine ganze Menge mehr
und schadet Russland aber noch mehr also
ich muss da gegenhalten die
russische Wirtschaft ist also deutlich
widerstandsfähiger als man behauptet hat
klar kann man natürlich jetzt hingehen
und argumentieren naja der rubol ist
stark weil sie wenig zu importieren
haben vielleicht haben sie die Zahlen
etwas frisiert vielleicht haben sie die
Zahlen also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass ein Land wie Russland
jetzt die Zahlen völlig sozusagen jetzt
fälscht aber man kann die so aggregieren
dass vielleicht so einige Zahlen nicht
herauskommt klar ist natürlich auch
sozusagen bei Ölpreis Bremse zum
Beispiel könnte man einführen aber
Russland hat Schiffe um 90 Prozent des
Öls woanders hinzubringen auch bei Gas
also auch bei sozusagen LNG Gas können
die natürlich die Transportwege sind
viel ich hatte auch im Twitter darüber
gestanden kriegt keine Ersatzteile mehr
für seine Schiffe Russland
wir hätten ihn jetzt international
isoliert so ganz ist das natürlich nicht
so wir haben den Iran zum Beispiel der
jetzt übrigens zum Beispiel auch wieder
Cola Dosen geliefert hat Sanktionen die
dann einfach ausgehebelt also heute zum
Beispiel Südafrika gesagt naja ich
beteilige mich nicht jetzt an diesen
Sanktionen also vor allem jetzt die
Yachten und so und wir machen doch eine
Gefahr wir schießen uns deswegen ins
nicht nur ins eigene Knie sondern
vielleicht auch in andere Körperteile
weil wir sozusagen diese diese diese
Blockbildung und da sind die Russen mit
ihrer charming-offensive deutlich weiter
als wie gesagt wir haben ein Alter und
da steht auch eine Rolle in diesem in
diesem ganzen Türkei also die versucht
jetzt aber mal so ein Mittelding zu
führen die die Ukraine mit Drohne
aber macht doch Sinn aus türkisch also
die Türkei bekommt jetzt günstiges
günstiger Gas die bekommen günstig ähm
sozusagen Öl und äh haben doch sozusagen
auch die mit dem mir also diese
Kreditkarten links was ja auch ein
völlig ja eigentlich ein schwieriges und
schwierig schlechtes
sanktionsmechanik weil das wirklich die
Bürger getroffen hat ja und es trifft da
die Bürger doch ganz anders als bei uns
ich meine die haben eine Situation die
durch die Decke geht nein also auch die
Inflation geht nicht durch die Decke die
haben die Inflation von 13%, die haben
eine Arbeitslosigkeit von 4%, also das
ist alles so ein bisschen man muss die
Zahlen wirklich mal differenziert
betrachten deswegen sage ich ja nicht
ohne Grund dass diese Sanktionen uns
mehr Schaden ich habe von der Türkei
gesprochen achso ja Türkei ja das immer
bei über 80%, das sind dann aber und
deswegen kann natürlich auch ein Erdogan
den kann man kritisieren in anderer
Stelle aber in dieser Politik hat mit
diesem Mittelweg schon eine richtige
richtigen sozusagen Ton getroffen das
aber ist nicht wenn man wenn man sich
diese Blaupause anschaut was passiert
denn in unserer Gesellschaft müssen wir
jetzt irgendwo sagen ja wir müssen auch
mal mehr ein bisschen was geben dafür
dass es Frieden geben kann müssen wir
auch mal ein bisschen leiden oder ist
man dann einfach sagen nein kann man
immer nur auf sich selber schauen aber
das ist das denn für ein Frieden
entschuldigen sie sagen was müssen wir
geben um Frieden zu geben ist das den
Frieden wenn wir jetzt Putin die halbe
Ukraine überlassen dafür dass Sie dass
wir wieder Gas bekommen und ist das ein
dauerhafter Frieden ich meine vor 15
Jahren hatte die Krim genommen jetzt zum
marschiert der ganz in das Land ein sie
glauben doch nicht ernsthaft dass wenn
wir jetzt sozusagen in die halbe Ukraine
geben dass er nicht in ein paar Jahren
kommt und sich und und sozusagen
weitermarschiert um den Rest auch noch
zu bekommen Frage ist also das ist ja
kein Frieden nee die Frage Frieden sind
wir bereit als Deutschland zu gehen auf
was wollen wir verzichten sozusagen
damit wir das mit genau das nicht
passiert Sanktionen zu akzeptieren und
weiterzumachen also vielleicht noch mal
dazu die uns treffen also vielleicht
vermeintlich härter als ihnen die These
ist also vielleicht dazu was ich meine
es geht doch nicht darum dass wir als
Bürger einen Winter davon sterben wir
nicht also wir werden auch einen Winter
vielleicht auch zwei Winter mit etwas
Geld über aber es geht um die Industrie
wenn die Industrie einmal weg ist also
heute war BASF das sind viele
Unternehmen die jetzt pleite gehen viele
sind kurz davor reduzieren sozusagen dem
Energiebedarf und dann freuen sich ein
paar Ökonomen sagen als schaut mal hier
wir sparen Energie wir sparen nichts das
sind Unternehmen die die Produktion
drosseln und wenn die einmal weg sind
dann sind sie für immer weg dann kommen
sie auch nicht mehr zurück es geht ja es
geht also nicht irgendwie dass der
Bürger natürlich was dafür zahlen muss
das ist klar dass ich finde auch dass
die Ukraine einen wohlschuld und eine
Bringschuld hat gegenüber dem Westen
dass fordern und völlig legitim und ich
verabscheue auch diesen Krieg aber es
geht um deutsche Interessen hier und ich
muss da sagen dass wir da einfach
vorsichtiger mit diesen ganzen
Sanktionen sein müssen dass wir
sozusagen am Ende gerade Deutschland so
ein Land was zu groß wie die Europa ist
aber zu klein für die Welt zu in der
sandwich-position das sind so Länder die
jetzt in der Kritik stehen und wir bauen
jetzt Anfang ab von allen Seiten und
dann müssen wir mal schauen ob das Ganze
wird es geht um Deutschland es geht um
die deutsche Position sagt Herr Aktas
wie wird das
diskutiert was glauben Sie wie ist das
in ihrer Generation jetzt also haben Sie
das Gefühl dass die Grundlage sozusagen
der Jugend jetzt auf dem Spiel steht
damit ein anderes Land die Ukraine
gerettet wird oder sagen Sie nein das
ist eben auch ein Zukunftsmodell für uns
für die Jugendlichen das ist etwas was
Europa ausmacht was eine Globalisierung
aus was macht ein zusammen ausmacht dass
man eben auch füreinander da ist und
dann auch verzichten muss und vielleicht
eben auch mal ein bisschen das
durchmachen muss ja auf jeden Fall also
ich teile denke ich hier die Meinung
dass jetzt wenn wir die Sanktion
zurücknehmen würden dass das der
komplett falsche Weg ist wir würden
Putin wir würden angekrochen kommen und
er würde sich tatsächlich bestätigt
fühlen was mir in dieser ganzen Debatte
in der Energiedebatte viel zu kurz kommt
ist dass er doch gerade jetzt die Chance
darin liegt dass wir doch viel mehr auf
Effizienz und auf erneuerbare Energien
und stützen soll also sie sagen wir
müssen unsere Energieversorgung
nachhaltig aufbauen da an dem Wort
nachhaltig ist nichts falsch aber als
Beispiel bringen sie Fracking was ja im
Grunde die unnachhaltigste Energieform
ist die es gibt wir müssen im Grunde
müssten wir 2035 klimaneutral werden da
wir jetzt Fracking aufbauen
das wollen wir gleich noch ein bisschen
diskutieren ich möchte eigentlich noch
mal ein bisschen beim wirklich beim
Thema Wirtschaft bleiben